america just one day away from getting a
new president
the national mall in washington has been
transformed for this occasion
you're looking at 56 pillars of light
illuminating nearly 200 thousand flags
last night representing
all 50 states and territory and
regardless of how you voted the
inauguration is typically a time of hope
for many and that's despite the
heightened security in washington d.c
right now more than
20 000 national guard troops are
patrolling a tightly controlled security
zone in our nation's capital
we've got a team of correspondents
covering this unprecedented moment in
american history and we're going to
begin
with jeff begaye's on new threats of
domestic terrorism jeff good morning to
you
what do we know yeah good morning tony
welcome to a heavily fortified
washington dc and you can see it behind
me you have members of the national
guard here at this
checkpoint they are armed and ready to
counter any potential violence and just
to give you an idea of how
tense the situation here is look at this
new intelligence that we're getting from
the fbi which says
members of the conspiracy extremist
group
q and on have been talking online about
potentially posing as members of the
national guard
in an effort to get closer to the
inauguration
cbs news has learned that federal
investigators are focusing on extremist
groups that may have scoped out the
capital and trained for the assault on
january
6. on monday police arrested two ohio
residents
38-year-old jessica watkins and
50-year-old donovan kroll
who are both affiliated with a militia
group and were seen in
photos inside the capitol during the
riot
law enforcement also arrested
22-year-old riley june williams of
pennsylvania
after she was on the run from
authorities court papers allege williams
took a laptop or hard drive from house
speaker nancy pelosi's office
when she stormed the capitol a former
romantic partner told the fbi that
williams intended to send the computer
device to a friend in russia
who then planned to sell the device to
svr russia's foreign intelligence
service but the transfer fell
through for unknown reasons thousands of
national guard troops are patrolling the
city
the fbi is now vetting all guard members
even though acting defense secretary
christopher miller said there is no
intelligence indicating an insider
threat
meanwhile police shut down the capitol
complex yesterday due to reports of a
nearby explosion but it turns out it was
a small
fire blocks away it's as vulnerable as
the government ever gets but i think
it's an important
message to send republican senator roy
blunt who chairs the joint congressional
committee on inaugural ceremonies
told cbs evening news anchor and
managing editor nora o'donnell an
inauguration is always an event to be
concerned about
the people here create a target that you
normally wouldn't have
i think we've made this as safe as we
can make it
with as much freedom as you could expect
to have and as much security as you
would want to have
senator blunt also told nora in that
exclusive interview
that he thought as many as 1 000 people
actually made it into the capitol
building on january 6.
and he also said this he said that if
president trump decides on his last day
to pardon any of them it would be quote
disastrous anthony jeff thank you 1000
that's a lot higher than originally
thought